ah why did the guy go
he was definitely round here hello
welcome to Playstation grenade a few
days ago another free-to-play battle
royale game finally made its way over to
ps4 and I've got to say I really like it
cuisine Royale it isn't the greatest be
our shooter don't get me wrong and it
isn't going to win any awards for
gameplay but it's super casual it's
completely ridiculous and of course it's
completely free and I think you should
give it a download
especially if you don't have any games
until Christmas Day arrives this is
cuisine Royale I played a few games
earlier today and here's the best bits
whilst I was learning how to win
I feel like GI Jane realistic waffles
and everything this I do really enjoy
this game it's not perfect it's a bit
glitchy yellow
hey it is a bit glitchy it's it's not
the greatest game in the world I just
really like it there's something about
him i dilute in because i was shot when
I get back I always seem to get shot
when I'm looting that's what happens
friends when you sneak up on a lady in
her underwear there we get it anyway
onwards and upwards
forget the pan and harass someone
someone definitely came this way there
he is there he is who shoot now I was
gonna go down the other side the
shooting through the wall oh no no no no
it's third pie the crap out of this wait
for them to start looting freak oh yeah
battle right oh look at the physics rag
doll a rag doll thank you for your time
I did I do believe it it's like a
camping game you can you can stay in the
same place long as you're in the circle
victim thank you for coming round is a
hog roast on the floor as you do Pizza
hog roast all the oils would you like
there's another one insane it was an
easy win
oh well they'd been fighting so long I
just want to see if the bush wiki thing
works one of you win the fight and then
come to the roads there he is there he
is okay let's get a better Bush will he
see us in this bush is the way to
winning cuisine Rio by Bush walking
there is come this way come this way
come this way not that way damn Yahoo
yeah this way yes that's good that's
good keep going will you see my fine ass
surprise [ __ ] Bush will keep
bother web this is definitely how you
play this game okay I look like I knew
how to cuisine Royale then so check me
out best in the world
dinner dude somebody's here somebody's
here somebody's here bust the bush here
the butterfly wow that was an insta-kill
right yeah you've got a butterfly you
see what the camera is now there's
actually a butterfly there or some sort
of flying bird so you can tell when
somebody else is around if they use in
third-person camera which I thought was
pretty cool
the top-two situation I can see the door
just shut like an idiot it's gonna run
for the door that's the best place to be
in there my jumper Susan
Thomas danger
I thought danger was his middle name
second again second we came again but
you have jumping shoes like this and
this is a world war two shooter this is
so weird
cuisine Royale I love you you stupid
pile of randomness
it's the pan on the head every time look
at the physics you've got to enjoy these
physics unlike a picturesque is it's
just a beautiful game really is see me
come on Springfield from this range oh
well my record up to that point was
second every time I can now add 38th out
of 43 to that record with zero kills I
am a legend
eat let's get the health back I'm gonna
one tap him ready whatsapp can't stir
them you know what I'm feeling cocky
we're gonna rush him with our axe
[Music]
instead what the heck is he doing
ah it's so difficult to aim with a gun
especially when you first start this
game cos it's just difficult we really
why have I got halo above my head okay
there's skills I have a halo why did the
guy go
he was definitely around here Knight I'm
ninth best in the world wouldn't kill
look I'll show you how difficult is to
shoot these two are still fighting now
look how close they are this game first
yeah so when you play in this
give it time because yeah the aiming is
difficult at first but you'll get it
you'll get it I promise all alone
somebody shooting at me : fella free hit
sniping in this game on controller
anyway is rock hard it's so hard I know
I've said this stabbed game so far but
this this is the one we win mark my
words
just ignore the other eight times I've
said this already we must get warning 10
here we go spawning in yeah I look like
a black crash-test dummy but we're off
let's get looting this is a lot shorter
ah there's a storm coming as it's got
any race submachine gun at this range
not really well this gets dark do not
get stuck in the dark zone still going
still code we're gonna win this I said
we're gonna win this we are going to win
this am I on the dark zone yet
hallelujah we eat and now we're ready to
win God's ultimate or basically don't
win so we must win if you're hearing
this
[Music]
[Music]
the only thing that annoys me is when
you aim sometimes it stays in first
person I'm gonna bushwalk you this you
think we can win bushwalking Inc do you
know why he's quite difficult to see
people bushwalk EADS does a guy know who
killed him
does the gun he isn't gonna clue he
doesn't know who killed him tie her
what's going on here okay that that two
kills one bush I feel like I've named a
film one on one this is the end of the
game this is gonna be our first to win
we're finished second too many times the
hell does that mean
what the heck is running on all fours ah
I all we have ultras we have alts brake
holding triangle I see what powers does
we slow down time that's weird
whoa did you see how quick he moved
no that's didn't you know what we've got
bass to the wall last eight games eight
games wouldn't win all right stay
completely still
I'll chase you down mofo
whoa action here
panhead does he see me does he see me
does he see me he does not the guy
inside here as well can you hear him oh
I'm right next to you and he never even
knew one another one coming in this is
really where the action is is he going
to loot straight away - I love this game
so much little we could actually hang
about near this loo and we could
probably get another couple of kills
let's start the wait they keep spawning
it spawning in and out that means this
is somebody some somebody here told ya
camp camp of Duty then oh well it's
another kill this is good
starting to get the hang of this game
loot and then we will kick on five left
so it's a one-on-one I'm in the best
position definitely they have to go past
me either above or below me they are now
they open the door area is 12 bullets I
have to hit all of them if this is going
to get us the win
Stowe's hits those headshots what was
that
Desert Eagle to the head that was
awesome that was so good
replay that like twelve times that's
gonna be the end of some sort video
hurts
you